I will here with Grandmaster Yasser
Sarah WA and past the US Champion Yasser
you have played a lot more chess and we
saw you last year last year it was like
a whole world of unknown do you have
more expectations for yourself this year
yes I come to the tournament feeling
much better about my own chest level and
more confident than I did last year
because I hadn't played in so long so
I'm looking forward to a great event and
right you essentially different last
year with lots of stuff of facing and
self-deprecating comments really deserve
rules yeah fully deserved but this is a
little more like you know your your
prior incarnation and chess simple
round-robin no funny business that
should make you feel little more
comfortable I would imagine big time
seriously there I think of chess in a
way as a very pure game right I mean
which it is and the purest form of chess
to my mind and you can't get any purer
than a match full stop Edna story but
then once you get away from the match
what's the next it's a round-robin
speaking of matches the World
Championship match is taking place
nearly concurrently do you think 12
games is long enough for each other no
what's your ideal number 20 seriously
much much longer I'll tell you 12 games
is too short and it's really too short
for players ok so I don't think you need
to go to 24 but I don't really feel
comfortable about 60
that's my I know you've been involved in
the past and lots of chest politics
trying to organize matches mediate
disputes and everything
why is chess politics so difficult I
just you know it's it's the weirdest
thing we do attract some strange people
in the chest and chest politics is
really one area that I really am trying
to stay away from one of those a lot of
countries around the world that would
love to have a fourth or fifth port on
their team like you well thank you all
the experience and the leader she could
bring me the team so we wish you well
I'm trying to qualify for his ten ball
thank you and we hope to see you there
me too thank you